I've been waking up at 2 a.m. and my heart is beating more and I can't get back to sleep.
What can I do about that? I'm not eating after 6 p.m. Thank you.
Okay, so if you wake up at 2 a.m. every night, what could that be a symptom of?
Well, there's a lot of things. But there's this hormone in your body that your
adrenalin makes called cortisol. Cortisol is released at times of stress. So if you're
driving down the road and you hear a police siren behind you and you feel like your blood pressure
just went up, your face just kind of flushed a little bit because you've got a little scared,
but after you and then they zoomed by you, you're like, that is a release of cortisol among other things.
There's some evidence for the release also. Cortisol increases your blood pressure.
So cortisol contracts your arteries, it increases your blood pressure,
because it's a good thing to have your blood pressure released if you have to run away from
a polar bear. So at times of stress, you sometimes need to flee. So you need an increase in blood
pressure to pump blood to your extremities and feed oxygen to the muscles so that you put a lot
away. So there's purpose of that song. Remember, every day is a balance. That's not a bad thing.
So cortisol is also released to the circadian rhythm in order for you to release
your glycogen stores in your liver. So glucose, you eat glucose, you eat food, you eat carbohydrates
that break down the glucose and the glucose excess glucose is stored in your liver as a long
chain sugar called glycogen. And glycogen then is released at times you need it like at times
of fasting. You release that glycogen stores in your liver. You're ready to 10k. You need glycogen
stores. At three mile mark, you have used all the glucose circulating in your blood to
contract those muscles. Now you need glycogen stores in your liver. So you'll release those
glycogen stores in your liver. You also need glycogen in glucose in your brain at night. So
your muscles might not be using a lot of glucose, but your brain uses glucose. The main food
for your brain is oxygen and glucose. And if you don't have glucose for your brain,
your brain is going to suffer. So you will release glycogen stores in your liver at night and you do so
by having a circadian rhythm, eating a rhythmic release of cortisol in the middle of the night. So
that's what could be happening. The problem is that if you don't have that rhythmic, so
so the argument here is, okay, wake up 2 a.m. with my heart beating more. So that is a heart beating
more is a side of increased cortisol. But I can't get back to sleep. That's a side of decreased
cortisol. So I know it's really confusing that I don't want to harp on this too long, but you need
that circadian rhythm release of cortisol to release glycogen to keep your brain alive at night.
If you have a decrease of that, so in the effect of adrenal insufficiency, you won't get that circadian
release cortisol. And you will wake up at night in order to kick in your adrenals so that you release
cortisol and that your brain stays alive. And those are the people that I wake up every night between
one and three o'clock and I can't get back to sleep. And it takes me a long time to get back to sleep.
Those people have adrenal insufficiency. Therefore, they have to wake up their body, their
brain wakes them up in order to get cortisol released through a different pathway, not the circadian rhythm
pathway, but getting awake, having to wake up, getting agitated, getting up, having to walk to the
kitchen, get a drink of water. And that's how your releasing cortisol. So the treatment for this is
typically you start by eating some protein before you go to bed, eat some protein before you go to
bed, see if that helps fix it. Number two, start taking some adaptogens to stimulate and
support your adrenal gland. And then if those don't work then let me know by the next zoom call.